now the high price of gas won't stop
tens of millions of americans from
visiting families for thanksgiving the
holiday is also a major test for
airlines 77 000 people went through
security checkpoints yesterday at
hartsfield-jackson atlanta airport and
errol barnett is on the tarmac of course
he is on the tarmac errol good morning
hey there nate good morning the stress
test is on look for most of the country
thursday and friday are days off but
here on the tarmac there's no such thing
so we've been spending time with the men
and women working this week to make sure
this flight behind me makes it safely to
boston and to make sure you can see your
loved ones face to face
a busy travel time like this it's hectic
it is one of the first steps in air
travel and the tsa officer unique nikita
lunford her goal is to help get tens of
thousands of travelers through security
smoothly we absolutely celebrate when
it's all over and and we can kind of
slow down and breathe a little for delta
airlines it's game time oh this is our
super bowl every year thanksgiving week
is when we see our peak travel demand
mark sparks is delta's vp of airport
operations here it may look like chaos
to the average person but i there's a
there is a ballet that's taking place
here at any given moment there's dozens
of aircraft and support trucks plus
thousands of airline and airport staff
all coordinating in real time
this area is what passengers don't see
on this day some eighty thousand pieces
of czech luggage will be sorted then
loaded onto planes it makes us happy
that everything finally is getting back
to normal karen barali and dion kofa are
part of delta's ground crew they're
thrilled to see the increasing number of
holiday travelers this year but some
airlines have struggled to get their
footing during the resurgence of air
travel during the pandemic southwest and
american airlines were hit with major
cancellations last month and many crews
continue to deal with the rise in
violent confrontations amid mask
mandates last year wasn't pretty it was
a dramatic change for us but one thing
about we didn't do we didn't fold we
didn't give up
when they call it quits delta says on
monday they had more than 4 000 flights
system-wide and are almost at
pre-pandemic levels this travel rush is
rewarding for former marine and 737
captain mark garner one of the more
gratifying things about flying on the
holidays is
you know
at the end of the day
we're going down the escalator and we
see families and friends getting
together and all this is to help you get
to where you need to be this holiday
season i'm excited to just see my mom
physically give her a hug after
two years almost
love the reunions so the next time you
look out the aircraft window spare a
thought for the ground crew who only
have about 45 minutes to completely
unload reset and reload the aircraft and
they do it each and every day gail no
matter the weather
i know i see a lot of people working
very hard to make sure your travel
experience is good and they take a lot
of pride in what they do thank you errol